[Music]
loyal
brave and true
uh
[Music]
need a hand little man
insult me again i'll take the tape off
my blade
lower your sword oh what
i'm your commanding officer fighting
will not be tolerated am i clear yes
commander
with your voice soldier yes commander
what is your name
harjin commander is this your family
sword
it belongs to my father rojo
following line
huh
huh
huh
[Music]
huh
turn
[Music]
you need to find the emperor we'll hold
them back
till next week
[Music]
six of our northern cities i've fallen
in a coordinated attack
their leader fights alongside a witch
crush these murderers your majesty
every family must contribute one man
to fight you're a war hero you've
already made many great sacrifices
my father cannot fight so i will take
his place
[Applause]
the northern invaders will kill her if i
expose her our own people will kill him
when we take the imperial city
i will take revenge for my father
what is your name soldier hua jin
commander son of kwajal
you will now take the oath of the
warrior
loyal
release
[Music]
you will die pretending to be something
you're not
yet here i stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our plans
[Music]
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
citizens we are under attack
this mulan story is as relevant and
resonant as it was when it was first
written over 1500 years ago
every family must contribute one man to
fight
we spent an extraordinary amount of time
looking for mulan
all over the world we searched every
village
and once i was in the room with yf i
realized that i'd found my warrior
loyal brave and true
i feel the strong connection between me
and mulan
she's very present and focused it's my
duty to fight
if i were your son you wouldn't have to
ife fits this world to a teek her
generosity her focus
she is mulan i will protect my family
she brings a sense of innocence
yet maturity to this version of mulan
we're going to make men out of
every one of you yifei was training
every day she is an accomplished
national artist
she can wield a sword she can ride a
horse
nobody else could have played the role
of mulan
disney's mulan rated pg-13 streaming
september 4th
every family must contribute one man
the world of mulan is so rich the
costumes
the colors the real landscapes and we've
assembled the most extraordinary cast
for this movie
led by lou yi faye nobody else could
have played the role of mulan
she's a brilliant actress but that was
only one part of the equation we put her
through
a grueling physical assessment she's an
accomplished martial artist
every moment yifei was on set she raised
the bar
and she inspired all of us
one of my favorite moments was shooting
donnie yen's
martial arts skills as commander tong he
does a sword display
in front of all of the recruits the way
he
moves a sword it moves so fast
i had to shoot the sequence again in
slow motion just so i could see what he
was doing
he is astonishing
this is a big vision of a big journey
and i'm so happy that we've been able to
deliver
an epic vision of mulan's story
i will bring honor to us all
disney's mulan rated pg-13 streaming
september 4th
you